Cerium is one of only two elements which,
if you strike it, will make
sparks. One of them is iron and the other
one is cerium. And so I bought
this when I was on holiday a year ago. I haven’t
had the chance to use
it. It contains, it consists of a rod here
which claims to have several
metals including cerium. Let’s see if it
sparks.
Ok so cerium, element number 58, has some
bizarre uses, would you
believe it’s used in self-cleaning ovens.
So it’s not very easy to do but, once you
get the hang of it, it does go
quite well.
Cerium also has uses such for staining glass.
So if you want to stain your
glass yellow then you could use cerium in
that.
What is happening is that tiny pieces of cerium
are being knocked off
and, in the air, they just burst into flames.
So, I think, the property is,
not so much that it forms a spark, but that
you can knock off the right
size lumps to make them burn. These things
that are being knocked off
are probably just a few nanometres, that’s
a thousandth-millionth of a
metre across so they’re very tiny size.
So then the surface area is high
because it’s small so it has a large surface
compared to its volume. And
so it reacts with oxygen very rapidly and
heats up and bursts into flame.
The point about cerium is that very small
particles of cerium oxide are
now becoming quite important in various areas
of technology. There’s a
company, or several companies, that are using
nano particles of cerium
oxide as an additive for fuels to make a particular
diesel fuel to try and
make it burn better and give more power when
you are driving diesel
cars. And here in Nottingham we are trying
to develop new ways of
making these nano particles by reacting cerium
with high temperature
water and it’s been quite successful.
It’s also used in organic synthesis by chemists
for making organic
molecules because it can be very reactive
under certain circumstances.
Cerium is also used in permanent magnets for
obvious applications in
magnetism.